9h à points 0,2 sous ce nom barbare se
cache la plus grosse turbine gaz jamais
produite à belfort est désormais la plus
puissante du monde
c'est la plus grande elle fait 800
mégawatts a donc pour pratiquement 200
mégawatts de plus que l'ancienne donc de
nouvelles technologies dessus un
rendement encore plus élevé 64% alors
que l'ancien était à 1 62%
donc c'est vraiment la dernière
évolution de la 9 h 1 on appelle donc la
9h 1.02 et pour transporter ce beau bébé
vers sa destination finale un convoi
exceptionnel de 876 tonnes a été mise en
oeuvre
on va jusqu'à strasbourg 6 jours
calendaires on met sur barge
on arrive au port d'anvers en belgique
et là il ya encore un peu près 40 jours
de traversée pour arriver en malaisie
dans cette période d'incertitude pour
l'entreprise
cette turbine fait figure de symbole et
démontre le savoir-faire des ouvriers
belfortain de general electric
on est très fiers en fait du savoir
faire dans nos usines que ce
savoir-faire il est menacé par general
electric et qu'on est prêt à faire des
moteurs d'avion parce qu'il ya un
business qui explose en ce moment c'est
le big business aviation chez general
electric safran a déclaré il ya deux
semaines qu'il voulait ouvrir de
nouvelles usines en france pensent que
belfort est la mieux placée
parce qu'a priori ce qui est compliqué
c'est trouver du personnel qualifié et
donc ce personnage et 10 sont ils à
belfort la turbine sera rejointe par sa
soeur jumelle en cours de fabrication à
belfort avant d'être mise en service
dans la centrale thermique de pas ils
goûtent gang au sud de la malaisie